[music]
ana
Well then, now that we've got all the drinks
, let's
introduce ourselves.
You're the one who's close to me c Go ahead, you're the one who
only blooms up to Anatsukiyama during the night Go ahead, I'll
make a girlfriend with Ion cows I'll make her this time I'll have to do my
best with Asta-kun's truck
Hey, hey, it's your turn  Introduce yourself to Myself Is it okay if I like what I like?
]
Self-introduction If you're a man, should you talk about your
dream?  Two people
No, I
've heard of the Magic Knights, but more importantly, the bottom professional 5 minutes Miya Kaido
Only a minor entertainer is a longevity tsukemen, so
of course the income, age, height, and social status must be higher than me
.  It's bad, it
doesn't feel so good